bien el día de hoy yo quiero hablar del
desafío de pensar algo que rara vez
reparamos en ello y que sin embargo
todos los días estamos haciendo pensar
nos lleva a actuar y actuar nos lleva a
concretar determinados objetivos a
concretar nuestra vida a hacer lo que
queramos
nos dicen cuando nacemos que podemos ser
todo lo que queramos es más casi nos
obligan a hacer lo que queramos pero de
repente encontramos que nuestro
pensamiento se enfrenta a muchos
obstáculos a desafíos en la forma de
pensar y uno de los más grandes es
pensar de conformidad con los demás
porque yo no voy a hablar de la
conformidad del conformista ese es otro
tema y a lo mejor puedes convertirte en
un conformista con tu forma de pensar
pero no hablo del conformismo cómo se
usa
tradicionalmente quisiera decir si no
voy a hablar más del conformismo de la
conformidad en la forma de pensar es
decir porque seguimos el pensamiento de
los demás cuando tenemos una capacidad
autónoma y aparte insisto en tenemos
este imperativo este imperativo de
pensar como somos para llegar a hacer lo
que queremos a principios de año
platicaba con me tocó moderar un panel
con los
directores
y rectores de las principales
universidades a mí me llama mucho la
atención que cuando a alguien le
preguntas qué estudio te contestan soy
ingeniero soy licenciado soy economista
yo creo que esa es una expresión que
reduce en mucho lo que somos porque una
cosa es que hayamos estudiado algo y
otra cosa es que seamos eso es bien
diferente y yo en esa conversación que
teníamos con los rectores yo les decía
porque las universidades no ofrecen los
programas para hacer lo que cada persona
quiere ser o sea qué pasa si yo quiero
ser médico médico de médico contador
abogado no hay un programa para eso
tendría que hacer tres carreras y es muy
difícil qué pasa con esa variedad eso
que necesitamos porque al final los
programas terminan obligándonos a
adoptarnos a ellos y eso que hace hace o
va creando esta conformidad que se va
haciendo más grande vamos siguiendo un
camino una vereda que se encuentra
despejada para caminar que no
necesariamente lo hacemos por elección
por comodidad y de eso es de lo que
quiero hablar bien
en los 50 es el profesor shlomó nadal
hizo unos experimentos sería
experimentos de naturaleza social uno de
ellos consistía en exhibir una línea al
grupo de participantes y luego un grupo
de tres líneas y la tarea que tenían
estos participantes era elegir la línea
del grupo de tres la línea que fuera
igual a la primera que extendiera muy
sencillo no el desafío consistía en que
todos los participantes salvo uno
estaban puestos de acuerdo para elegir
la línea equivocada
al pasar un turno el que no estaba
puesto de acuerdo
elegía la correcta todos los demás la
equivocada otro turno lo mismo elegía la
correcta todos los demás la equivocada
para el tercer cuarto turno el que elegí
a la correcta termina por escoger la
equivocada
porque ese esa es la presión social en
la que estoy hablando una presión que te
obliga a pensar equivocadamente aún
cuando sabes el camino correcto y esto
lo comprobó el profesor shlomó nas e
insisto es uno de los estudios más
ilustrativos de lo que estoy hablando
hace algunos años
álex tello hizo un estudio sobre el
número favorito de las personas y
encontró que el número favorito es el 7
no es muy difícil adivinar esto cuando
nosotros pensamos en un número de la
suerte cuando pensamos en un número
favorito el 7 va a aparecer en nuestra
mente y esto es un reflejo de una
tradición milenaria
de apostar por este número de
considerarlo un número como algunos
dicen cabalístico quizá por eso la
semana tiene siete días
hay siete maravillas en el mundo porque
no pueden ser más porque limitarlo a
siete el siete es considerado el número
de la suerte en las vegas' e incluso
blancanieves tiene siete enanos como
compañeros todo esto aquí donde voy
hablando hasta donde voy hablando estos
dos casos tienen que ver con la
conformidad que se creada no esta
conformidad y que vamos nosotros que se
va generando socialmente que quienes se
van agregando a la sociedad van
adoptando de manera muchas veces
involuntaria sin embargo hay algunos
rebeldes como el caso aquí coge que a
pesar de que a él le decían que la
barrera de las dos horas en un maratón
no había un ser humano que pudiera
romperla él decidió hacerlo y
conseguirlo desafiarlo y conseguirlo él
se reveló a la conformidad y lo logró en
una hora 59 el sistema el sistema no le
reconoció su logro y sigue siendo
controvertido porque quizá porque
queremos que todos actuemos y pensemos
de conformidad y si la conformidad nos
dice que no se puede no se puede aunque
se pueda
pero este señor lo intento y lo logró
después me topé con la historia de kris
wilson y me llamó muchísimo la atención
es es un hombre que se equivocó a los 17
años fue condenado a cadena perpetua a
esa edad por haber cometido un delito
grave pero llegó un punto en su vida a
pesar de que los custodios y todo el
personal del penal donde se encontraba
recluido le decían que ellos se iban a
encargar de que nunca pudiera salir de
que nunca cambiará porque no cambian los
que se equivocan él hizo un plan él hizo
un plan
hizo su master plan como lo llama en su
libro hizo una lista de más de 100 cosas
que él tenía que hacer levantarse
temprano hacer ejercicio hacer algo por
los demás
comer bien leer etcétera y ese plan se
lo presentó a su cuenta el juez que
llevaba su caso y con este plan el logro
convencer de su cambio es más no antes
de convencer de su cambio logró cambiar
logró revelarse a su condición de
convicto en cadena perpetua y cambió el
destino de su vida logra salir cuando
sale sale una casa de custodia y ahí a
través le dicen nos vamos a encargar de
que vuelvas al penal no logran una vez y
vuelve a salir y logra sobreponerse al
final a ese destino a esa conformidad
donde el delincuente es delincuente y
donde la readaptación es sólo una
narrativa y se convierte en un
empresario y hoy es una persona muy
destacada igual que nos hace
conformarnos o revelarnos donde llegue
ese ese rompimiento con nosotros con
nuestro pensamiento con la sociedad
donde donde llega ese punto donde
podemos desobedecer donde nos permitimos
desobedecer donde primero nos rebelamos
para que para desobedecer para cambiar
las reglas para cambiar el orden de las
cosas pero sobre todo para cambiar
nuestra vida
al final estas son opciones que tenemos
a lo largo de la vida conformarnos
actuar de conformidad con los demás
conformarnos al grupo convertirnos como
el grupo o concretar lo que queremos
son opciones que tenemos desde que
nacemos y como lo dije hace un momento
de repente hasta se vuelve un imperativo
pero un imperativo que se espera o que
el sistema no está preparado para que
cumpla
porque siempre va a ser más fácil ir
detrás de los demás siempre va a ser más
fácil escoger lo que los demás no nos
vayamos lejos con respecto a cómo nos
vestimos pues hay un consejo que
establece el color del año y alrededor
de esos colores se hace la ropa y el
diseño de la ropa lo decide también un
consejo de moda y todo lo que vestimos
por más que tratemos de individualizar
lo responde a una conformidad entonces
mientras no nos demos cuenta seguimos a
los demás ahora aun y cuando decimos
bueno yo tengo este despertar y no voy a
actuar de conformidad con los demás
tendemos a equivocarnos es decir nos
queda claro que nos gusta más a qué ve
tenemos y tenemos claro que nos gusta
más ve que sé pero elegimos por qué
ocurre eso
y uno de los grandes enigmas que todos
los estudiosos del comportamiento han
tratado de ir resolviendo y aquí tengo
un ejemplo en el caso del fútbol
en el caso del fútbol los porteros se
quedan parados en el centro de la
portería sólo el 2% de los tiros a gol
que les hacen cuando se cobra un penal
sin embargo los tiros que se hace en el
centro que se hacen en esa dirección
sólo son el 17 por ciento o sea porque
no son el 100% sí ahí es donde tienes un
98 por ciento de probabilidades de
conseguir el gol
pues hay una lógica como retorcida donde
el jugador prefiere disparar a un lado
porque parece que disparar el centro es
como bobo es como no lo más inteligente
no es lo mismo fallar disparando al
centro de fallar disparando buscando un
ángulo donde el tiro no pueda ser parado
vean otra vez es una lógica como
perversa retorcida que nos hace pensar
más en lo que se espera de nosotros
desde el punto de vista de imagen que
desde el punto de vista de objetivo
y aquí el punto es que es bien difícil
decidir con claridad ya que voy más a un
tema desde el proceso de pensamiento
nos enfrentamos a obstáculos nos
enfrentamos a diferentes barreras para
llegar a donde queremos y una de ellas
que me encanta recurrir a cuando cuando
hablamos de esto es la alegoría de la
caverna de platón platón decía que
estamos todos encerrados dentro de una
caverna viendo sombras y que damos
reales las sombras estamos bien creemos
que esa es la realidad sin embargo la
única manera de poder ver la realidad
tal cual es es salirse de esa caverna y
a lo mejor entrarás en otra
pero vas avanzando
vas cambiando vas desobedeciendo
te vas alejando de esa manada
por otro lado tenemos los errores del
pensamiento los errores cognitivos
tenemos errores en el procesamiento de
la información que va ya que es una de
las actividades fundamentales el
recolectar información pensar y decidir
pero en este camino hay errores que
algunos científicos han encontrado que
no son aleatorios sino que son
sistémicos sin embargo te puedes poder
romper es esa condición siempre y cuando
seas consciente y algunos de los que
quise traer a la mesa son el sesgo de
prueba social es decir si a todos les
gusta si todo le dan like y todo le dan
5 estrellas es porque es bueno así
pensamos tiene que ser bueno los que
leemos vemos un libro lo ves con cinco
estrellas lo compras y resulta que no te
gustó no lo entiende si tenía cinco
estrellas cuando eres como los romanos
esa es la solución simplemente no eres
como los demás y lo que les gusta a
todos no tiene porqué gustarte
tienes que encontrar su propio gusto el
riesgo de optimismo creo que empuja
mucho que podemos hacer esto porque
creemos que las cosas siempre van a
estar bien
yo pongo mucha atención en los que
hablan de eso no no es que todo está
bien traver explícame porque va a estar
bien ahora en la pandemia muchas una vez
que todo está bien yo lo veía en ventana
no voy a encargarme porque va a estar
bien si en aquellos momentos con no hay
vacuna no vemos avances no vemos ninguna
medicina vemos vemos a la gente
muriéndose porque está bien solo porque
creemos
porque tenemos esa inclinación a pensar
irracionalmente que todo está bien
otro de los sesgos es el sesgo de
confirmación que nos hace
poner atención selectiva
en aquellas cosas
pues tienden a fortalecer lo que
pensamos
ok lo que nos da la razón y eliminamos
lo que va en contra entonces imagínense
este cóctel donde hay un sistema que te
propone que pensar y luego está esta
recepción de la información y esta
decisión que puede ser defectuosa por
este tipo de sesgos podríamos combatir
de alguna manera siendo conscientes
y ahí es donde se va preparando toda
todo el terreno para él
lo bueno es que siempre se puede revelar
el juego aquí con la palabra cambiando
los caracteres para para ir por los dos
significados revelarte como como un acto
de resistencia y el revelarte como un
acto de mostrarte de conocerte de
entenderte
camus en el hombre rebelde definía de
qué se trata esta rebelión él decía que
el hombre rebelde es aquel que se alza
se quita sus cadenas y dice las cosas
hasta ahora han sido así pero en
adelante ya no piense lo interesante se
llega un momento donde tú dices hoy está
bien las cosas se han dado de cierta
manera pero ya no quiero que se ha
nacido ahí es donde empieza ese acto de
rebelión donde empieza esa esa
desobediencia a uno mismo ante ese acto
de rebelarme de mostrarme de entenderme
también muchas veces un obstáculo que se
nos presenta en el camino una
experiencia fuerte en rompa nos hace
recomponer lo y cuando hablo de
conflictos cuando esté tratando
conflictos con las personas cuando
alguien me invita a ayudarlos a
resolverlo les digo que el primer punto
es que cuando hay un conflicto hay
demasiadas oportunidades detrás de eso
el tema es entender lo que hay las
oportunidades y dos trabajar para
aprovecharla
ahora qué podemos hacer para revelarlo
yo les diría primero que nada el viaje
empieza descubriendo quién eres
realmente y para descubrir quién eres
hay muchas herramientas yo les diría
hagan omeyer brics en línea y entiendan
más de ustedes no dejen esas cosas para
cuando te piden trabajar con que alguien
más nos analiza y alguien más decide
quiénes son
hagan ustedes antes les puede explicar
quiénes son pueden explicarse a ustedes
quiénes son el otro punto es
entender cuál es tu visión de la vida
que la que le da el valor que es lo
realmente importante para ti cuál es la
definición de vida la tuya no la del
libro de autoayuda cuestiona sus
suposiciones
te crees con duda y qué crees de manera
absoluta hay oportunidades para cambiar
la narrativa que estás
platicando te y que está guiando los
actos
muchos se preguntan cuál es mi objetivo
o te obligan a decir oye cuál es tu
objetivo creo que hacer la pregunta
equivocada la verdadera pregunta es
cuáles son tus objetivos y porqué cuáles
son tus objetivos por qué somos
seres multidimensionales es decir no nos
expresamos de una sola manera nos
expresamos en diferentes
mundos paralelos y podemos ser
diferentes cosas a la vez y es algo que
cuando lo entiendes potencia mucho tu
capacidad de hacer y de vivir
aprovechemos eso en una misma vida puede
ser escritor puede ser músico puede ser
profesor puede ser un empleado eres
padre de familia eres hijo y cada una de
esas canchas tiene un objetivo diferente
y una vez que entiende esos objetivos
hay que ver como decían los estoicos
marco aurelio de que tienes control
sobre que tienes control sobre que
tienes control parcial y sobre que
tienes nada de control y entonces sobre
eso haz un plan y trabaja sobre las
cosas que puedes controlar para
revelarte para desobedecer
y la pregunta es qué estás haciendo con
tu vida qué has hecho con ella hasta hoy
y no la respuesta pero si el consejo es
que aproveches lo que te queda de vida
hay relojes que te van dando el tiempo
no del día pero el tiempo que te queda
de vida de acuerdo a la expectativa de
los demás y cuando eres consciente de
eso te das cuenta de que todavía puedes
hacer muchas cosas no de que el tiempo
se está acabando
rebélate contra y a ti mismo yo los
invito a ser anti héroes haciendo un
viaje porque los héroes todos hacen lo
mismo pero los anti héroes se preocupan
por hacer las cosas diferentes también
buscan hacer las cosas bien pero buscan
sus propios medios no te pases la vida
buscando tu propósito si no vas a andar
como perro tratando de alcanzar la cola
porque el propósito está en ti y no está
en otro lugar encuentra lo nada más en
ti encuentra que te hace vibrar darte
cuenta de qué es lo que te hace fluir
apuesta todas tus acciones al presente
pero no por vivir en la inmediatez sino
porque estás construyendo un futuro y
acuérdate de que vale mucho más una hora
de vida haciendo lo que realmente
quieres si eres que pasarte la vida